Hello Freak bitches.
Hey,
check this out.
I want her to ask you what do you,
what do you think is Trump going to do anything about the stratospheric aerosol
injection?
Write that down.
I
run.
We're talking about stratospheric aerosol injection.
I can't get to you the points that you want.
Let me,
you know what do you think Trump wants to stop that?
I'm going to chuck.
Write it down.
Write,
write down.
Then the next question,
I'll do it here.
That's the question.
The question he just five before the Alex Jones is off the rails right now.
Folks
get the joke.
Why don't have to write it down.
I didn't get it because you've been bad.
Listen,
will Trump is Trump
that program to stop the old one?
Well,
what do you,
what do you think the program is ending?
What do you think the program,
the director of the CIA,
he's talking about it on Youtube.
Look on your Johno.
Johno Brenda.
They talk about strategies.
They talking about strategy and solid injections.
It's going to cost $10 billion a year and there's going to be some countries
opposed to it because it's going to mess up the web.
Telling me about atmospheric manipulation,
and I'm talking about stratospheric g s I'd never heard of that.
It's super important when you can break it down to three letters.
Yeah,
let me,
let me go.
John.
Oh,
Brennan admitted last in June of 2016 at the it,
I saw the video comment on it.
Can you play a Jamie John O'Brien talking about this forever?
No,
I'm not.
I'm not bashing you.
But you had your TV show made jokes about it,
which I get because a lot of it to be,
yes,
there is an entire atmospheric terraforming geoengineering manipulation.
They don't call it chem trails.
And of course the CIA director admitted they had this huge program.
Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation owns the major patents on it from Westinghouse
and others.
They use these big antennas to manipulate the weather.
They can,
uh,
like China's like causing huge harp like harsh technology.
It's all declassifying harp manipulates the weather.
They admitted to us.
I used to have the head of Harp,
general bitten k part.
Not all the time,
but exactly.
There's giant weather modification systems and there's weather wars between
different governments and they,
it's all declasse explaining to people that are listening what harp is,
what does it stand for?
High altitude something.
Yeah.
They've got a system that supposedly you don't know what to Harper really was
under his classification.
What does it stand for?
High frequency active auroral research programs.
So the idea behind this was they wanted to do research on the Aurora and didn't
they want to see if they could communicate using it and send radio waves.
They want it out over the horizon radar.
Right.
Yeah.
That and they also wanted is to be able to send radio signals to places where
they wouldn't really hard.
It doesn't really go,
what does that have to do with stratospheric aerosol and just really go into the
atmosphere?
Well,
the speculation,
I've interviewed the private head of it.
Okay.
Let him work.
How does harp work with the chem trails?
What do they,
let me check goes on.
Okay.
Only a my chronic amount of small amount of what harp does is in the atmosphere.
It's bouncing off the Aurora borealis and then resonating back through in a,
in a deep earth,
uh,
communication program to satellites and other things through the planet.
So it's still does he communicate satellites through the satellites down to the
submarines.
So here it goes.
This is an actual definition.
How harp works.
The facility's transmitters send radio waves upward when,
hold on,
let's just read it first waves upwards into the ionosphere between 100 350
kilometers of altitude.
The resulting heating effect creates irregularities and the electron density
there,
which in turn allows communication signals as from satellites to be relaid off
the ionosphere.
And that's not what it really does.
Then they can shoot the shadow light frequency coded through the Earth to
submarines.
Now what is this website from then?
The son Jamie bully.
You want the real stuff?
I'll tell you.
Yeah,
sure.
Okay,
let me explain something.
Okay.
nature.com I have the head of the heart program on,
I'm just fucking,
I got contacted about 10 years ago and they said the head of the Hart project
really lecture work.
He liked to come on interviews online and he liked to come on and tell her buddy
and about 30 minutes in a colonel came on the line and said,
sorry during a break and cut the guy off.
Whoa dog,
Tom.
Tom In.
This really happened Q spooky music cue.
Spooky music building.
Get back.
I believe that's a true story.
I want to know.
I want to know that.
I want another relationship between like what are the chem trails have to do?
Do you think Trump is going to look into the SIA project at the CIA has
greenlit.
He is starting out with vaccines.
As I told people he would do investigating and all the damage they've caused.
All this amazing.
Then the ultimate.
That's good to start the vaccines get that shit together too for sure,
but what about the SAI programs at the CIA has greenlit you think he's going to
get into that?
The other gets the next level.
She's really wanting to communicate with these microphones.
Internet shouldn't be like,
I want to have to split it all up.
You're so locked onto this.
It's like,
here's the problem with all this essay.
I saw a shit.
Most of what you see when you see those jets flying around those clouds behind
them,
most of that is just a jet engine.
Exactly.
The Jeremiah confusers that with a real newsroom.
What's the real program?
Well,
here's the thing.
You're writing,
so as Joe,
because the world is complex,
there are secret and clauses,
Shaker and in public programs to test manipulation of the weather and weather
systems.
The Arabs are doing it.
The Chinese are doing it.
The Russians are doing it.
People being cloud seeding for a hundred years.
My cloud,
Johnny's redounds to whether manipulation,
but they're doing it for different puddles.
It's not not not to produce flops.
I had been living kick on the head of the U s whether weapon program for 27
years on my show first because I saw it was he classified.
I saw that he was in the panhandle of Texas.
I called him running a major clouds city company with his son and got the nine
year old to Austin and then after that he totally freaked out cause the CIA came
to his house.
Do you want the interviews on Youtube?
Do you want to know what he said?
Yes,
he was a World War II fighter pilot and say at the end of World War II he flew
the first planes in the hurricanes,
which,
what's your,
you know the Atlantic that's pretty gangster and into typhoons that are even
faster in the Pacific.
And then he,
and then he also led squadrons in Vietnam,
flooding everything up to 10 feet of water out of clear blue skies with an hours
with their width,
their chemicals on a pass.
You have to be to do that.
Super Bad ass fly into a hurricane or a typhoon.
He's the first guy to do it.
Holy Shit.
Anyways,
he's super bad ass.
Let me know.
He's alive.
He's been living at 90.
He was still all there and I thought at not he could kick my ass big tex.
And I felt like I was,
the guy was tougher than me anyways,
so,
so we're sitting there and he gives me all this data and I can't believe it.
He sent me all these classified photos and stuff cause they just declassified
the file and no one thought to call the old man from Lubbock or whatever it was.
So I call him out getting him on.
They sent a bunch of people to their company and threatened them.
The next week after I hired him and he laid it out,
he said in 1967 we certified at the Stanford Research Institute that he was able
to control hurricanes,
create hurricanes and steer hurricanes,
all that got black budgeted shutdown.
And then they got into these arrays where they could use antennas and out of
that,
and Westinghouse came,
came the uh,
the,
the whole heart program show in the 60s.
They could create control and steer or kill hurricanes.
That's why you Google now bill and Melinda Gates bought all those patents and
the quote,
Bill Gates is going to save the world from bad weather.
Bill Gates wants to stop hurricanes.
Google it.
So I,
so let me deal getting sounds.
The weather machine,
let me pause for a second.
How does the,
how does,
how do they manipulate a hurricane?
So the hurricane's going to happen,
how do they break it up?
Okay.
If it's,
if it was coming into lands there,
problem with,
with Ariel arrays projecting into the sky,
they can break it up or strengthen it or kill it or steer it because it's all,
he's doing that with harp.
Well they've got,
they've got heart-based is all over the place.
They call him doppler radar facilities.
Oh the government wants your local city.
They have doppler radar.
I thought that it was like,
so you could ask the guy in front of the waiter the screen,
that's it.
Like one 10th of 1%.
They can crank those arrays up that have massive,
your lights might go when they do it a little bit.
Yeah.
Cause they'll use the whole power of your town through the doppler radars then.
Then they control it.
The US has a giant weather weapon hidden in front of everybody in every town and
city and poor Russians and Chinese are just discovering it.
All the U S has one of the weapons that can knock them all out.
Right.
You Know Bill Gate's control,
the weather ideas for barges to pump cold water from the depths of the ocean to
create some sort of a roadblock for the hurricane.
Since her gains pull power from the water's warm temperature is cooling.
The water could have theoretically theoretical lessons.
Right.
Dismantle the hurricane.
Well it sounds like a good idea though.
None of it.
The point is we are loving.
He is it doesn't that sound like a genius idea.
He's spray cold water and cool off the trails.
Johno Brennan in in the front of the CFR is saying we were doing this because w
for global warming and we got to save them.
You are writing,
you are writing about social,
about about Geo Engineering and chem trails.
You were wrong about the dinosaurs not being wrong,
but hey,
what about that they're,
they're coming out saying,
hey,
there's going to be some countries that don't,
that aren't going to be for it and we got to figure out how we're going to deal
with them because you want me to have the audience?
Yes,
yes.
Was the big season manipulation.
Keep going with that.
Come on man.
Don't change the subject.
Keep going with that.
You're not done with Livingston.
Imagine you're here.
But imagine that me and Joe are actually come on and got me off on you want be
hear about Ronald Reagan to later finish the s AI pro.
He doesn't know about this.
I know about it,
but it's like a monitor.
Dale,
what do you know about the Sei program?
Look,
let's get this done.
When most of the real programs are just like fronts for something else.
It's not even real.
So you don't think they're spraying shit into the atmosphere?
No.
There is a program for Geo Engineering.
There's a program in place and you said it's the doppler radar system and a harp
and what else?
And an aerial spraying still the most effective and they,
when do they do have pat?
When you say aerial spraying,
what are they spraying?
Barium salts,
alumina oxide,
radioactive isotopes brain in the air and doing that and he alone was because
because it does a bunch of things or testing a bunch of stuff.
They're,
they're,
they're manipulating things.
Listen,
our pedagogical way.
Why do you have evidence that they're doing this and a spraying aluminum and
Barium,
whatever it is in line and reads the Department of Energy.
It's all public.
Just like he just said,
go online and watch a Chinese dude get jacked by a tiger.
I agree.
That's out there.
You go to the Department of energy.gov right,
and you can watch CFR.
She CIA director at the time.
Brennan it admitting all of this.
This is all public.
Yeah.
He admitted it.
He talked about,
but he'd know I saw it.
I saw the video.
We can play the video and go over it if you want,
but he's talking about various options for controlling global warming.
They're laying out the future.
Look if global warming,
there's a guy,
hold on a second.
If global warming is real,
we know it is right.
Don't you think they would have?
You don't believe global warming is real when they keep measuring these
temperatures and scientists keep saying this is the hottest year on record
church.
Let's emails.
Well,
let's find out.
Let's find out what the muscle,
Jillian's real.
Okay.
I believe that goes,
it goes high,
it goes cold.
There's always micro temperature is always like to change.
This shift stretches.
The only thing that ever happened.
That's a,
I think we all agree on taxes to Al Gore won't fix it.
Okay.
I think we all agree that's the shifts,
but what I'm saying is there absolutely is global warming,
right?
What does a C minus?
We're talking house.
When my dad was a kid,
the 1950 [inaudible] for three,
four months out of the year,
it was below zero or freezing and you had to chop wood and he'd freeze your ass
off in all houses had even in the south had had uh,
you know,
had all sorts of of chimneys genom for fireplaces because it was freezing cold
and now there has been a warming period,
but that's part of a normal global cycle based on the sun.
All these astro physicist or,
sure.
The whole thing about claiming it's the carbon we put out the earth is carbon
starve.
There's a carbon cycle.
That's the big point I want to get to.
The globalist want to tax if they can tax oxygen,
carbon dioxide,
water or sunlight,
they have total control over the whole lifecycle of the planet.
Let's play the video.
This,
this CIA guy talking about it because what I inferred from and decide to come up
with some sort of solutions.
If global warming becomes a giant gay Brennan is a fricking known,
will hobbyist what it was,
yo,
hold on.
What is the CIA that's watch the video first?
Global warming.
It's a good question.
What do they have to do?
I don't know what the CIA does.
Intelligent communism.
They were built that stop the spread of communism,
but it's an intelligence agency.
They're part of the environment.
Okay.
They were part of the intelligence community and if they got hired,
I would imagine,
this is just me guessing right off the top of my head.
If they got hired to assess a threat and a threat being from global warming,
like what?
What do we have to worry about?
Are we really gonna lose cities?
Do we really have an issue there?
The current goes down.
Give George Soros and the UN total power for a 100 trillion per decade.
Global tax to micro manage and surveil everything humans do.
Let's see.
As of carbons toxic,
they've got a surveillance.
Thus they have a jurisdiction who control controller lives.
Okay,
hold up.
Why does it say debunked?
CIA director admits chem trails,
geoengineering,
stratospheric aerosol injections.
Uh,
so it says claim guys.
Brandon wrote,
hold on,
hold on.
At the counsel admits geoengineering.
In the form of stratospheric aerosol injections.
Sai Is taking a place he Kempter is taking place,
IEE chem trails,
and the rebuttal is nowhere in his speech.
Is there an admission that an sai program has already taken place?
The part where Brennan Mentions geoengineering is just one example.
Out of several not often mentioned issues with the CIA monitors for potential
elements of instability in the world.
A S AI program,
if ever implemented,
could penetrate conflicts and security threats if misused.
The CIA's jobs to consider all types of concepts,
concepts for potential future problems and threats,
including the science oriented concepts.
That's totally fine.
Let me break down.
Right,
but isn't that possible?
Done,
but what that guy just said,
is that possible?
No.
That's basically what Brendan said.
But what he's saying is that there are potential threats.
You want everyone to watch her mentally it's an issue,
right?
So he's not admitting that he had,
there's an sai hard,
but when we want to tell you,
okay,
go ahead.
Tell me
everybody debates how many programs or are all the specifics.
A lot of that's classified.
You can Google Shyna lodges,
Major Weather Control Operations 10 years ago or Qatar does it,
or Saudi Arabia or UK or for sure people have studied.
No,
no,
there's,
they call it study or there's a giant hell in 2005 the Department of Energy
Program for aerosault testing with $5 billion a year.
She'll under US code title 50 Chapter 32 subsection 1,528 paragraph B.
Is that true?
You nailed that,
right?
Yes.
We from Mars under US code.
Do you live on that obelisk?
That was fucking insane.
Let me just tell you,
I can't even remember the time.
The last time.
The Cida fire
under US code title Finish Hammer 32 1,528 paragraph B.
That's insane.
Hold on.
Say it slow and let Jamie write it up.
Jay was code title 50 chapter.
I say it fast.
Remember us?
Code Title 50 Chapter 32 30% section 1,528 paragraph eight subsection 128 the
real fast brain fact speed.
Kenya's speech came and say it.
He has like one thought you,
Jesus [inaudible].
He knows one.
There's restrictions on use of human subjects for testing of chem trails.
Go back,
go back,
back.
There you go.
Or biological agents,
right now what they do in this flow is they say it's illegal to test unless it's
for research.
Then you're allowed to leave to kill people.
It was for research purposes.
That's how some of those Japanese whaler vessels get away with killing whales.
Still.
They say it's for research purposes and they kill the whales and tell them it's
from dark shit elites or the mad scientist engineers.
I'm gonna give you the big secret man.
And if you want,
yes I do.
I'm up here in the room.
I know.
I'm not even saying they call.
They're the high priests.
They're scientists,
they're engineers.
They're allowed to kill people,
test stuff on kids and jet black people would shuffle us all the declassified
stuff because they are scientists.
All the real executioners tortures,
or most of them were people making decisions are doctors.
And so it's all medical doctors stuff and this big breakaway civilization of
scientist.
Okay.
And so that's what they've built it under,
under under research perse visions.
They could even kill anybody they want.
Yeah.